foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
hell boy oh boy
a lot of news over the weekend
[Music]
I this becomes a theme on Mondays
where over the weekend uh it is America
so we have to
um run for our lives in this country
when we're at shopping malls when we're
at churches grocery stores I mean you
know
the Newfound freedom of having to dodge
high-powered rifles
um you know
it's a freedom that we have in this
country to
um to be terrified that some
Maniac who is allowed by Republican
policy to receive any weapon award that
they may wish any amount of magazines
and to hold as many rounds as they
possibly can to kill your family in
front of a shopping mall that's the
Newfound Freedom that we have in this
country and if you don't like it well
then I guess you're just unpatriotic and
Un-American and you don't understand how
the Second Amendment works
well
I am I have to say that I am super
pissed last night I did a patreon Sunday
rant and I tried not to yell and scream
into the microphone and I would like to
make that promise this morning but I'm
not going to because
um I'm still debating whether I'm going
to show you the videos
of this or not
um still to this very second
I'm debating whether I'm going to show
you the videos of this
I think everyone in the world should see
what is happening in this country I
think everyone in the world should see
the grotesque Battlefield images of a
little child having their head blown off
in Allen Texas because Republicans think
that is the price you have to pay for
the Newfound freedom of
not valuing life in this country it
really is weird
um coming from a bunch of people who
stand in front of women's health clinics
holding signs claiming they're pro-life
when they would go to a mall protesting
people giving Candlelight vigils to
um victims of gun violence because they
believe in the gun violence
what do you want from me
wait what do you want you want me to
feel sympathetic for a bunch of [__]
people who capitulate to these
[__] listen if you're not if
you're not speaking out to your friends
your family your colleagues the people
at your church if you're not saying
something then you're not doing anything
if you're not calling your congressman
and your Senator not just your [__]
the United States Congressman in the
United States Senator I mean your
[__] state senators your state
representatives and I don't care what
state you live in and I don't give a
[__] what the laws are
it's enough of this [__] [__] and let
me tell you something if it takes the
people in this country looking at a
little child having their [__] head
blown off and their brains splattered
all over the sidewalk in front of a
shopping mall then so be it
you're Europe you're more offended by a
photo
of a child having their [__] head
blown off then you are giving the access
and the ability for anyone and everyone
to get a weapon to blow a child's head
off [__] you
you go to hell
[__] you it's enough of this stupid ass
[__] where we have to pretend all kinds
of garbage we have to pretend that it's
your uninfringible right it is not
you're uninfringible right [__]
it is not
we are the government we are the people
let me tell you something you [__]
gun nuts and I've been telling you this
20 30 years from now there's going to be
serious talk about about repealing the
Second Amendment
serious [__] talk I can already see
it in our future 20 30 years from now
if you keep capitulating to the people
who are dumping weapons of war on our
street murdering our innocent [__]
people wanting to Shop grocery shop go
to school be in a classroom go to church
go to a [__] parade
you're out of your you're outside your
[__] mind if you don't think that the
collective of people in this country
especially the the generations that you
have terrorized terrorized since you let
the assault weapons ban lapse
you think they're not gonna do anything
about it
you're a [__] bonehead
you are a f and if you're a liberal out
there and you own these style weapons go
turn them in now right now right now and
make a video show force that we are not
gonna do this anymore not one gun is
worth this not one gun is worth the
image of that little child having their
[__] head splattered all over the
sidewalk in front of an h m and now in
Texas
it's not rocket science
and everyone in this country should be
pissed right the [__] off
that anyone anyone would stand and say
well that's just the price you pay
that's just the price we pay
that's just the price we pay for what
you to believe that you get to do
whatever you want whenever you want
however you want kill whoever you want
with whatever weapon you want [__] you
you can you can piss off that is not
that is not what the Constitution says
that is not what it says you are not the
real well-regulated militia that you
think you are
and to people out there that believe in
the Second Amendment still
rather it be to the extent that these
[__] lunatics on the right believe it
to be which is a way way far gone
misinterpretation I was listening to a
debate yesterday in Twitter spaces it
was supposed to be about these people
being slaughtered in Allen Texas and
they ended up talking about fences and
front doors on schools
why do we let them listen if there's a
right winger talking about how they
should own weapons of war they don't get
to debate us
you just say [__] you I'm not listening
to you you are a dumb [__] you
don't get to be in the discourse we do
not have to allow them to be in the
discourse
frankly I'm I'm one to think that if
you're against red flag laws and you
come out publicly against red flag laws
which is a bare minimum which isn't even
gonna come close to solving the [__]
problem but if you're against red flag
laws you get red flagged immediately and
law enforcement comes and confiscates
your [__] weapons
it's enough of this [__] white gun
culture [__] that's what it is it's
white fragile male gun culture
that we get to do whatever we want
whenever we want with no consequence in
this country [__] you that is not what
freedom is that it's not what Liberty is
your freedom your rights your liver your
equity and your equality do not come
without consequence
and just because we Grant the right in
the Constitution for people to own
firearms doesn't mean we do it without
consequence
but if we can't handle knowing the
consequences of dumping weapons of war
on the streets then you don't get that
freedom
it's enough of the [__] it's enough
of the Cross talk it's enough
Americans are sick and tired of having
to go to a mall and figure out where the
best Exit Plan if someone starts firing
a high-powered rifle at him
it's enough of it
and if it takes if it takes the images
of a family being ripped apart
by high velocity
ammunition coming from a semi-automatic
high-powered weapon of War so be it
so [__] be it and you better look at
the [__] picture of the guy who got
had they had to [__] execution style
shoot him in the [__] face to stop
him
there was a cop there he heard the
gunfire real time
there is no good guys with guns that are
gonna stop the bad guys with guns the
guy that got out of the car and murdered
the family standing in front of the h m
thought he was the good guy you dumb
[__]
he thought he was the good guy
he thought they were the bad guys
without guns they had shopping bags you
know
it's a real threat
you better pluck your head out of your
[__] ass and I'm talking to everyone
not just you two aprils if you people
are not on the phone calling your
[__] state congress people your
United States Congress people your
Senators I don't care what state you
live in ring their [__] phones now
if you're not talking to your family
your friends your colleagues and telling
them this is unsustainable we have to do
something and you don't want to know
what that something is vote Republicans
out
vote them the [__] out
how don't you see that this is
Republican policy that is dumping these
weapons of war on the street and killing
our [__] citizens killing children
splattering their brains all over a
sidewalk in front of a shopping mall in
Allen Texas it's you Greg Abbott that's
the blood on your [__] hands
it's enough of side stepping and
bullshitting each other it's enough of
it I'm sick of it
bullshitting each other like oh well you
know there's a lot of things we can do
about this there's a lot of things we
can do about that we could do this with
that and we could do this here over here
shut the [__] up shut the shut the [__]
up it's the guns it's the [__]
guns and it's the white gun culture that
has
[__]
place these policies in these states to
allow these weapons of war and this gun
culture to sweep across the [__] the
country
and put high-powered weapons of war in
the hands of people who think they can
get away with anything
foreign
and we have to push [__] back and if
you aren't pushing back at all you're
part of the problem that's right you are
part of the problem if you won't speak
out
is it dangerous sure it's probably going
to be dangerous
but you're going to be shot out anyways
so what's the difference
you're I'm telling you in the next 20
years if we don't do something we as a
people we as a collective
if we don't do something you're going to
be shot at you're going to experience a
mass shooting event somewhere in this
country
I don't give a [__] what state you live
in what town you live in if you think
it's rural if you think it's all it's
the city if you think oh this is a great
part of town doesn't [__] matter
that this is in front of of an H and M
folks [__] pulls up in a car
gets out and just starts killing people
and if you're defending if you're
defending this person's right to do this
you are a vile piece of human trash
you are a vile piece of human trash if
you're going to defend the right for
anyone to get a gun and it's just it's
just the consequences that we have to
pay for freedom because we don't have to
pay these consequences we don't have to
do this stupid [__]
we don't have to put up with it we do
not
and the only way to stop it is to elect
people who are serious
about setting policy for gun safety in
this country
serious about it
and I believe
that what we should do is move the
entire goal post
move the entire goal post and say
repeal the Second Amendment repeal your
right to own a firearm you want to [__]
around find out [__]
because I'm telling you over the next 30
Years 30 years from now
if we continue this way there there will
be real consideration to repeal it
this is unsustainable
in this country
unsustainable we cannot do this
we're killing children who haven't even
entered this world yet pro-lifers you
love unborn children
more than you love
the little child
who had their head blown off in front of
the h m and I say it that way [__] you
you think it's you think it's too harsh
well that's what happened
you want me to tell the truth that's
exactly what happened
Greg Abbott allowed this lunatic and any
lunatic in Texas to get whatever gun
they want whenever they want he's
encouraging it [__] he was bragging
about how California had more gun sales
in Texas we need to change that
as if more guns is the solution
got out of the vehicle
with the high prior weapon of War
walk towards a child and blew their
[__] head off
right over the sidewalk brains out
murdered the family
the first responder gave an interview
on the news no one had a [__] chance
no one had a [__] prayer
if you caught one of these
High Velocity rounds just right you're
done
and then and and then we got to talk
about the motivation as if the
motivation is the key point
I mean these are white supremacist he's
a [__] proud boy he was wearing proud
boy Insignia on his [__] body armor
that's why the cop had to shoot him in
the [__] face because he had body
armor on because the cop's not running
around with a high-powered rifle
in a mall parking lot he's got his
sidearm he's got his pistol
the more of these red States strip away
these laws to keep their citizens safe
from catching a stray bullet in front of
an hmm or shopping mall or grocery store
[__] wherever
then
I would guess that the less they're
tourism is
going to afford them Florida Texas the
state of Missouri I I there's a [__]
viral video going around today of
someone walking around St Louis with a
[__] rifle just like it's nothing
like they're carrying a goddamn grocery
sack
this is unsustainable
and if you don't realize that then you
need to pluck your head out of your ass
and you need to do something about it
I'm telling you
call your state congressman call your
state senator call your governor's
office I don't care what state you're in
call your United States Congressman call
the United States senators call the
senators of Texas
cornyn and Cruz
it's time
it's time we get loud
talk to your neighbors your friends your
colleagues
this is not going to go away just
because
and the solution is clear again I know
it [__] hey politicize you're making
politics out of it yeah
Steve scalise who is a [__] victim of
a mass shooting
said we don't need politics we need
prayer no we need politicians with some
[__] guts that's what the [__] we
need we need politicians with guts who
isn't going to give a [__] what the gun
lobby says not gonna give a [__]
if a handful of families lose a little
bit of profit in this country because
they own the gun manufacturing plants
[__] you
that's what we need
and there ain't a one of them not a one
that has any kind of courage in the
Republican party every [__] one of
them are cowards
why do you think they're doing what
they're doing which is nothing talking
about thoughts and prayers you [__]
coward
you you don't think these politicians
have seen the [__] images of these of
these crime scenes
that we saw on social media almost
instantaneously after the Allen Texas
shooting they've seen these pictures
and they can sit back and go well you
know [__] that's just the that's just
the price we pay
can you imagine Ted Cruz and Greg Abbott
seeing the photos and the pictures of
the crime scene at Uvaldi
I mean just this one child in this video
at Allen Texas
having their brain splattered all over
the [__] sidewalk
is enough to make you want to puke
can you imagine
Greg Abbott what cut what kind of sick
[__] what kind of coward do you
have to be
to see those images
and to continue
to just
hope and pray
that people don't get slaughtered in
your state
and it's boy a lot of shit's happening
in Texas
isn't it
I knew I was gonna get pissed off today
what are you gonna do what what what
other [__] What other state of being
what other mood do you want Americans to
be in
after hearing the news at Allen Texas
and not only that seeing those [__]
images you should be one pissed off
[__] this morning and tomorrow
and the next day and yes am I saying you
know what at Sandy Hook if the public
would have seen the pictures of those
dead children slaughtered by a weapon of
war in that Elementary classroom more
would have changed by now in Uvaldi
at Parkland in the Buffalo grocery store
is it a sad state where we have to where
we as a collective have to view what is
happening in this country and what I
mean the consequences of what we are
doing to each other
by capitulating and you may not think
you're capitulating you're like oh Tony
well I'm against high power rifles I I
tweet that we should have a assault
weapons ban great
fantastic call your congressperson
call your [__] Governor call them
don't stop calling them every [__]
day send them emails don't be nice don't
[__] get yourself in the trouble
because there's consequences to your
freedom to call them and to email them
but tell them how you feel that we have
to stop this nonsense they have if they
won't pass gun reform you will unelect
them you will vote for the other person
especially if they're a [__]
Republican
the blood is on their hands here
and to act like both sides are the same
this is such [__] nonsense and both
sides are the same with guns I'm sick of
hearing that [__] too [__] you you
[__] Democrats where they can
all around the country are trying to
pass any any sort of gun restriction
that they possibly can
but it doesn't prevent the flood of
weapons from these [__] states that
that
give anyone and everyone access they're
dumping these guns on the streets in red
States that's the whole point
Jesus Christ I listened in this Twitter
space the other night about someone who
was like oh well in Mexico they have all
kinds of guns they only got one gun
store and they got all kinds of yeah
because they're coming from over here
in these red states where you don't have
to you can have straw purchases
at gun shows
and I I'd say this I I know it's it's
not a uh it's not going to be an
electable issue
if Joe Biden has a certain stance I get
it I understand that
but when he wins in 2024 I think Joe
Biden should sign an executive order
Banning assault weapons
Banning High Pass capacity magazines
unilaterally [__] them let them take it
to court do it
do it let's find out [__] them let's
find out
past Universal background checks with
the stroke of a pen let's find out if we
can do this [__] or not
they won't do it Congress won't do [__]
[__] them
[__] them [__] them [__] them and if
anything we should give them the
majority of the house and the Senate and
maybe he'll have a bill to sign for
crying out loud
we have to get back to Common [__]
sense in this country and it does not
make sense what happened
at Allen Texas at Uvalde at Buffalo and
on and on and on and on and every
[__] day in this country it goes
we do not have to live this way it is
our choice that we are living this way
and I know you say Tony I I I'm against
this I'm what did Den Yellen scream
yell and scream
it's enough be loud
there's a lot at stake in this country
not just not just our lives and US
dodging bullets there's Women's Health
Care there's parental consent
Jesus Christ there's just a love who you
want to love to read a [__] book is
that threat in this country Jesus Christ
the Republican party is more worried
about Mass bookings
at libraries than they are
about anyone and everyone getting a
weapon of war and just killing whoever
they want in front of the h m
it's crazy and it's ridiculous and I
know I know the lead story is Trump's
deposition
but I can't I cannot get the image of
that little baby having its brain spread
all over the sidewalk I can't get it out
of my [__] mind and I can't stop
being pissed off about it I have
children I want to go to a [__]
shopping mall without having to worry
that my family is gonna get murdered
because my Governor decides that it's
more important for people to own weapons
of war than my [__] family being safe
you you cowardly vile pieces of human
trash that are Republicans
it's enough of it
speaking of human garbage
I'm going to show you
I'm gonna show you videos of the king of
human garbage
the crown jewel of trash that's right
Donald Trump
um deposition we got the scripts and
several weeks ago about what he said but
we're gonna watch the videos we also
have a new edition of what was that
I think we're going to watch that today
so don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube
you can watch the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
you can follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google also
I want to thank everyone with for all
the support over on Twitch our twitch
following and our Twitch account is
growing fast fast fast it's free to
follow over there but if you have a
Prime account
we have an Amazon Prime account you can
show us monetary support
without costing a single extra dollar
just link your Prime account
to your Twitch account
and you'll be able to
um give us a few dollars of Amazon's
money
on the subscription again it's free to
follow but you can link your Prime
account to give us the one free
subscription you get with it to our
Twitch account which gives us a couple
bucks every month so thank you very much
for all your support of it don't forget
to uh renew your subscription every
single month as well I just noticed
someone re-subscribed here and we've got
a few new subscribers this morning so
thank you very much helping us out over
there on Twitch everyone stick around
we're gonna be back right back with more
and there's plenty of [__] news all
right we're not going to fit it all in
in two hours the Ridiculousness that's
going on but
we're gonna do it we're gonna try
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show I got
announcement to all the people over
there on the up wire Channel
[Music]
on YouTube you go to upwire.com
find the YouTube channel or just type in
the up wire when you get to YouTube
I want to welcome Jim to our Mod Squad
he's moderating over on the upward Jim
welcome welcome welcome everyone welcome
Jim over on the up wires Channel
if you can if you're over there and he's
going to be helping out to mod on the up
wireless channel so thank you Jim for
being over there and supporting us on
the UMP wire and being a mod he's
they're pointing out this morning he's
the first boy mod
yeah well
Jim I like you but you know women are
better than men it's just the truth it's
the truth if you don't know that already
well then you're doing this whole
[__] thing wrong
the whole thing the whole [__] thing
wrong if you're not aware of that but
Jim thank you for being in The Mod Squad
now welcome Jim over on the up bar like
I said you can go to upward.com and you
can find the link for the YouTube
channel there or if you're on YouTube
you just type in the up wire in the
search bar and you'll find the up wires
Channel we broadcast from there every
single weekday as well also on Facebook
if you have a Facebook account at the
Tony Michaels follow us on at the Tony
Michaels you can watch the broadcast
every single weekday for two full hours
there as well
you know I think I want to do um we're
gonna have Gabe Sanchez come and join us
here in just a minute and we're gonna
watch his new uh what was that
uh and I'm still trying to decide if I'm
gonna play this footage from Alan Texas
but let's shoot the [__] for a minute if
you got a question throw it in the chat
here uh sorry I haven't been watching
the chant this morning I've been a
little pissed off oh man my eye is still
red I I mowed my yard over the weekend
and I think I got like like piling her
[__] in my eye
um someone was trying to give me
antihistamine drops or allergy eye drops
and I just I don't like antihistamines
they make me feel like [__]
so I don't know you get that too like
when you you get your allergies going
and you take Zyrtec I'll take like
Zyrtec for like three or four days and I
feel like garbage I mean just straight
[__] trash and the Benadryl is the
same damn way
I I [__] hate antihistamines I don't
know maybe I'm allergic to Aunt is me
[__] I don't know
it's crazy but my eye is bloodshot today
I swear I haven't been drinking I swear
I swear man and my my eyes yesterday
felt like
swollen as [__] but this one is red
like a [__] I mean this one's a
bloodshot but this one's really red I
don't know
I don't know
um let's see do we have any questions
here for shoot the [__] everyone was
commenting last night
um
on
on the patreon the Sunday rant about my
pink guy Tony
now I I mean I don't think it's pink I I
haven't had anyone you know [__] on my
face
and then I can remember over the last
couple days you know I mean maybe but I
I don't recall
than happening
but yesterday after I I mowed my eyes
were oh and it's because it's so dry
right now where I'm at in Central
Missouri it hasn't rained it's supposed
to rain this week a lot
it's supposed to storm a lot which I'm
hoping to get rain because it's so dry
when I was mowing it just
um I mean it's just like clouds of just
oh it was horrible
it was horrible and as I get older my
allergies get [__] worse you guys get
that
God damn this [__] well what are you
gonna do okay
um
Missouri Dry yes Missouri is very dry
right now
Missouri is Missouri
driest we haven't had rain Rhonda Rhonda
on Facebook
[Music]
um
and Laurie says Benadryl makes me loopy
it just it makes me feel like it makes
me feel like [__]
I used to be feeling [__]
and someone says uh Tony clear eye drops
Works [__] wonders
and I live on Zyrtec D Suzanne from from
YouTube yeah is that the one with um Ben
Stein Clear Eyes
are your eyes clear and dry is that the
one is that the one it might be and I
might and I have some
um some eye drops
but
I don't like to use them
um someone says use saline to rinse your
eyes out have you saline on my on my
nose for like allergies and stuff this
is kind of the same thing I don't know
I'm crowd surfing medical advice here
although it it's it it isn't itchy this
morning it's just still red so it's not
itchy as much
I guess
then my eyes normally are it just it's
red
it's just red
someone uh Sage says eye drops are bad
for you I try not to take anything any
kind of medication other than
Jagermeister that's the only medication
that's the only medicating that I
actually do okay
no I I try not to take anything like I
have to have a pounding headache to you
know take something for a headache
I try not to take anything I try to
power through it I just feel like
anything that you're taking
of something that you can just work
through and it's it's you know maybe you
got a crick in your neck or something
like that every once in a while you
gotta have something right you just
gotta make it through just get you
through but
um eight of wand says my only drug is
Advil
[Laughter]
only drug is Advil
and David says the uh Budweiser is the
best allergy medication is it really you
know um
they say eating local honey is good for
your allergies uh look Robin's right on
top of it
I just I just thinking that she's
thinking the same thing I'm I'm thinking
they say eating local honey is um is
good for you because you know the bees
will go around collect all the pollen
from all the things that you're allergic
from and they make honey out of it and
then you eat it and you get you know you
get a buildup of immunity from the
allergies but like around here it's so
dry right now that all the cars are like
green from all the tree pollen and [__]
like they have this green Haze on them
my God damn and then when you mow the
yard all that [__] is sitting on the
yard right all that pollen and [__] is
sitting in the lawn
when you're mowing it just kicks up all
that dust and it's dust but it's it's
all the pollen that's sitting in the
yard too because they hadn't had time to
the Rain hasn't washed it down into the
Earth
Yeah Boy And then you get what looks
like pink eye looks like someone's been
you know farting on your face I don't
know maybe someone was it could be it
could be who else does anyone have a
question are you just giving me medical
advice
Daniel says why not try Ivermectin you
know it's it's true could be
it I mean that that's I mean I'm not
saying maybe you know I mean it would be
just as effective as it was with covid
maybe so why not
why not medicate with the horse based
oh there's anyone we're gonna have Gabe
here in just a second we're gonna watch
this uh his new what was that does
anyone have a question here and then
after the uh what was that we're going
to um
we're gonna go over some of the E Gene
Carroll Trump deposition I want to show
you some of this [__] I cannot believe I
cannot believe that we are going to have
the opportunity of airing
this these video depositions of him
uh during the election the general
election they're still behind this
[__] even after this weekend
listen any other any Democrat
that had deposition this [__] bad
that country would abandon them
immediately
um Jan Riley says are the Jaeger are are
there Jaeger eye drops I'm not sure Jen
but you know that's not quite a bad idea
you know what I mean
just saying you're saying
let's see what else do we have here why
are Americans not capable of protesting
like Europeans that's a good question uh
we watched um
we watched uh some video what was it um
last week of
um in Paris I believe it was Paris
France or they lit a cop on fire for um
changing their retirement age by two
years
boy you think we could stage a goddamn
demonstration here uh super Saint on
YouTube says Tony Brownsville I'm I'm
guessing your your meaning the um
the people in the migrants in
roundsville that were sitting outside a
migrant shelter
and um dozens of them sitting there
along the street and someone in an Su
comes along and plows them over it it's
intentional
um they're trying to figure out if it
was or wasn't but here's the thing is
apparently they can't identify this
person they've arrested this person
um but they can't if they won't tell
them what their name is they give them
false names it's clearly intentional
it's clear the intent that they had was
to mow these people down
um and my guess is if they identify this
person and have the evidence of the
intent then it's possible that there'll
be Federal hate crimes the weird thing
is is the vehicle I don't know if
they've confirmed yet if this was a
rental car but the thing is is if it's a
rental car you'd have to have some sort
of identification to rent the car so
someone had to rent the car or was it
stolen I mean what the hell is the what
the hell's deal here
um so it's it's very sad what happened
in Brownsville again there's more
footage of the Brownsville
um
killing where the person mows over a
bunch of people sitting on the curb
um at the aftermath which
listen the reason why the Republicans
want to dehumanize people is because
when we see these images
the humanity is shown plain and clear
and the inhumanity really more than
anything when you look at these images
of these people being slaughtered in
front of the h m and you look at these
people being mangled up by an SUV
because they were sitting on a curb
waiting for a bus
when you see what what the result is
it's inhumane what these people are
doing to us
and it's it's it's because of Republican
ideals this is this is their [__]
culture
this is their culture I mean this is the
same culture that led Kid Rock to
[__] use his semi-automatic rifle to
mow down eight cans or eight cases of
Bud Light and pretend like he was gonna
boycott him when he was still selling
beer in his Nashville bar same [__] it's
the same white gun culture same [__]
same [__] the same stuff it's the same
thing where we watched um we watched
several videos of this guy with a bunch
of mannequins in his backyard you know
shooting at him and [__] and hitting on
them and thinking that he's some kind of
[__] gravy C or some [__] you know
what I'm talking about it's white gun
culture
these these fragile white men
are desperate to remain relevant
desperate so much so that they're
willing to go to the extent to pretend
that they're oppressed
and that their oppression must lead to
them acting out
it's really [__] dumb but that's what
it is
um Adam wands said here's a question how
can we start a nationwide anti-gun March
I mean I'm not saying we can't
I mean I I I think it's not a bad idea
I think but I think what is really going
to get a movement going is to tell these
Republican politicians that we will
unelect your dumb ass if you don't
change your mind
and there's a video
um from a Texas State Rep that I want to
say show later and he said the word
[__] during a press conference and
the reason why is because he's [__]
had enough of this [__]
they're just sick of it
um and we've got Gabe Sanchez Gabe we're
we're doing the um
um shoot the [__] here real quick while
we're waiting on you nice um did you
wipe your ass did it clean yeah I did I
wiped it so good I just want to make
sure
I'll give you Sanchez on the entry here
have you seen those commercials uh on
Instagram for the butt deodorant
what
yeah I mean maybe maybe Instagram just
knows my ass smells but they keep
advertising butt deodorant to me
uh are you not cleaning yourself in the
shower no no no no I'm not wash I wash I
washed like why would you
so that that there's a there's one
called Lumi I think it's called okay I
don't know you know what maybe we should
I I'd have him as a sponsor here why not
yeah okay I'm curious man I'm gonna look
this up and now it's gonna track me so
let me
deodorant yeah that's that's for private
parts outrageously effective whole body
deodorant for pits privates and Beyond
aluminum free baking soda free and skin
free who's it for
it's mainly geared towards women but
they have yeah he says yeah there's a
Mother's Day sale right yeah but there
but there's that there's a man there's a
man they have a man kind of butt
deodorant yeah
is this better than soap
what do you mean
like no no no no it's just to keep your
crack from smelling you know in the
meantime right so like I look at the I
look at the website and it's a sticky
deodorant so I'm like [__] use this
stick down there well I mean you lift it
up I guess you know you apply it what do
you want why why would I why would I put
it so you're telling me I got to use the
same stick down there and over here no
no no no no you can get two different
sticks you have an ass stick and a pit
stick I don't know man this is three I
was like something someone's gonna get
confused with wait a second I'm telling
you no I'm telling you on these videos I
it's not that I've watched them or
anything like 15 times on Instagram they
keep advertising this to me and I think
because I'm like maybe this maybe this
is something I should be doing you know
what I mean
I I don't know I mean
I've ever heard of this thing really
yeah yeah I I didn't know the heard of
crack deodorant no because I [__]
wash my body yeah well right right but
you wash your pits right I wash it all
okay so you wash your pits do you put
deodorant on your pits after you get
done washing it yeah like once I put my
clothes on then I'll put deodorant on
right wait wait wait wait you put your
shirt on before you put the deer yeah
because here's the thing you put
deodorant on and then you put a shirt on
then you get those like the roll on the
side of your shirt like sometimes it'll
that's why you got to do it after you
put the shirt on so you don't get it on
your clothing
what
all right look I'll ask him again all
right here's here's a pull for the group
ready you can just say yes no because
I'm not in the studio right now when you
use deodorant
do you put deodorant on before you put
your shirt on or do you put it on after
you put the shirt on
all right so Catherine Celeste Smith
says I'm with Gabe after after before
after see it's after for sure after
before before after before see here's
the so this is the problem especially
when you wear black shirts or like dark
colored shirts I I don't get [__] on my
it's not there though what happens is
when you put it on it gets rolled up to
the bottom it's on the sign on the
bottom yeah yeah
just ask your wife she probably didn't
say anything she was like
that's what I'm worried about that my
ass smells and I can't smell it right
you know what I mean it's just I just
you know what I'm thinking right I just
play it safe where I don't want to get
on my shirt so I put it on and then I
put it on after
and it's easy I mean I reapply sometimes
after if I've been sweaty you know I'm
like yeah I might I might see people I
think people are getting confused in the
chat uh Nanette says Gabe let it dry
first and then put the shirt on properly
why can't I get clothes first and then
put it on so that it's all done I feel
like I don't want to have to I don't
have to air it out and then wait to put
the shirt on I wanna I'm dry after the
shower so I put the shirt on and then I
put the stick on I don't have to worry
about it getting on any clothing
this is ridiculous
I'm seeing a lot of I'm I'm seeing a lot
of Afters baby all right so so now now
now search the butt deodorant because
the Lumi the Lumi is
I'm talking about the man maybe we
should reach out to them to see if I
would solid cream bundles yeah see they
got a cream so like you know like you
see I could I could understand like
women using wipes right I feel like
that's what you're thinking of wipes why
would you put a [__] why would you
put a bar on down there
haven't you ever had swamp ass are you
applying are you just rolling a stick on
your ass that's what I would do oh my
God I'd get the deodorant I feel like as
a wipe it up that's down my crack I mean
I would do it after I cleaned I wouldn't
you know I wouldn't be riding dirty and
take my deodorant my ass you know what
I'm saying all I'm saying is it just
makes sense from a product standpoint
like if I put on my product development
hat right
it makes sense that a white reception
you would use down there as opposed to
[__] rolling on a stick it doesn't
make any sense doesn't make any sense I
think I think the stick makes complete
sense just like you do it doesn't make
any sense yeah you would do it in this
yeah
you think a woman wants to it's that
doesn't make any sense a wipe makes more
sense than a stick
it doesn't make any sense look I'm sure
if we ask people in the chat they would
probably agree with me and say a wipe
makes more sense well I'm trying to get
them as a sponsor now so you might have
to I'm you know what if we do get them
as a sponsor I'm gonna make you do the
read that's fine I'm happy
you'll probably send samples and you'll
be like the butt gear is the best thing
ever
actually you won't know anyone who gets
near that region would know right right
right you know what I mean yeah no
totally like a soap a soap in the shower
that makes sense but a bar after you're
on like a bar to use post shower as
opposed to a wipe like soap in the
shower makes sense wipe after the shower
makes sense a bar for down there after a
shower
doesn't compute for me man man what what
what's the problem I don't see what's
the problem it just doesn't make any
sense why would you use a stick of
deodorant down there so your ass cheeks
don't smell
oh my God just use the wipes
to me to me the logic is like so okay so
why don't you use wipes on your armpits
you can use wipes on your armpits right
but why don't you because I have a
deodorant stick that's intended for my
armpits right and I for my I want some
people may have a deodorant stick that
is
here's area
deodorant for my armpits
or or a deodorant stick for my armpits
not for my privates
what no yeah I think these I think this
is an intelligent idea I think this is
great I know it doesn't make a lot of
sense to me I think it does I think it
does anyone who's ever experienced a a
Rancher case a swamp ass would agree
with me
I would love to see a demonstration of
some dude on this website go on you ever
had swamp ass well now here's the Cure
and then he like pulls off the top of
the deodorant stick
and he goes ah you smell that ladies
yeah and you're like that's right you
can't pass
done no more swamp ass haven't you ever
put a what's the other one like uh Arm
and Hammer the um
uh uh wow why am I watch the commercial
okay there's a commercial
this is a one okay all right fine I'm
gonna watch the commercial right now I
mean we can we can watch it here live on
the air if you want to see the link yeah
sure yeah okay
see they're agreeing with means
you make any sense why would I use a
stick for my privates now now
um Danny brings up a good point a lot a
lot of dudes will powder and wait that's
what I'm saying there's the problem is
is that the the powder
baby powder has been known to cause
problems down in the areas as well
because the powder keeps you dry I have
a really good story about baby better by
the way oh okay I was gonna say we and
yeah I've got a story where we we dumped
a bunch of baby powder on a friend and
then dumped a bunch of water on them
because obviously the way that it reacts
is a super cooling effect
uh and that was something where it was
pretty funny to watch us hit someone
else with a bunch of Arm and Hammer baby
powder and then a bucket of water
uh but I've never I haven't really used
it since I was younger to do that one
it's like when I lived in in the midwest
when it was like humid ass Heat
yeah well that's what I'm saying I live
in the midwest as human as [__] here you
get you get rancid cases of swamp ass
you may need some rancid man I don't
know Tony's Ranch so here's the
commercial and again we're not a
official sponsor I've never seen this
commercial and I'm I'm hoping she
doesn't use the stick down now but who
knows you see the situation that's going
on here though yeah yeah yeah I get it
okay all right all right well let's
let's see what happens
hi I'm Dr Shannon klingman founder and
CEO of Lumi the aluminum free deodorant
for everyone's everything we're talking
armpits lady bits under the testicles
the testicles the butt cracks and sweaty
backs also feet so why am I hanging out
between these stirrups this is where
Lumi was born as a woman I have spent my
fair share of time in this seat
self-conscious about my bottom half
draft also my feet and as an OB GYN I've
seen countless patients who've been over
diagnosed for odor below the belt it's
your vagina's fault antibiotics are
often over prescribed whenever there's a
concern about odor I knew this
never-ending vagina blame game was lazy
and much more often than not wrong so I
started to think outside the box and
worked my smelly butt off to prove that
the problem wasn't in the vagina it's on
the skin and it's everywhere it's
bacteria bacteria was my father call me
Carl kind of cute for a sweat blood and
semen eating organism you see depending
on the fluids
different odors emerge so it's not even
really you that smells it's Carl
[Music]
Lumia tax odor at the source stopping
Carl from eating in the first place hey
Carl what's up okay
just click the link to slay your steak
forever Lumi is the world's first whole
body deodorant stop okay so now you're
getting the drift yeah yeah right but uh
the only demonstration I saw was she she
put it on the armpits and then she
rubbed it looked like she rubbed the
stick and then put it on her feet so is
she rubbing the stick and then rubbing
it down there well I don't know well why
don't we finish the video okay well well
let's you find you preemptively stopped
it now I'm curious I want to know let's
find out am I think Leo before it even
happens 72 hours stink free everywhere
on your body his big deodorant's worst
nightmare you see most big Brands want
to bully you into trying a bunch of
different products that will only cover
up Carl for a few hours so you have to
keep buying and applying and I've never
liked bullies oh
the world deserved a better different
deodorant one for all it took me 10
years to perfect gloomy and after all
the blood sweat stinking tears yum got
me poop we proved Lumi was six times
more effective than other leading
natural deodorants Lumia is aluminum
free baking soda free and hypoallergenic
so you can use it on your most sensitive
skin from the pits to the balls okay so
did you see that little tube there where
you're gonna yeah yeah that's a cream
note different than a stick man
different than a stick so you're okay
with the cream cream I can understand a
cream a cream a wipe that makes sense
but a stick doesn't make sense to me man
it just doesn't add up it just won't
wipe the stick in your butt crack why
would I use a stick on my butt crack or
it's almost gross or my balls I'll use a
cream also I don't want I don't want to
rub my butt hole out of that [__] I'm
trying to think how we got here and this
he told me oh yeah I asked if you uh
yeah and I've never heard of this thing
this is uh this is something else man
all right well let's keep going I don't
want to be accused of not watching the
entire video and getting the entire
context so let's let's continue this is
hilarious of your feet rather than just
trying to cover up odor with aggressive
sense Lumi smells like a brief fleeting
whiff of Science and then nothing at all
like the back of your hand
we have tens of thousands of five star
reviews and a 60-day money-back
guarantee because we expect you to
expect more now that's confidence so
click the link to enjoy a world without
body stink with Lumi the better
different everywhere deodorant boom
loomy [__] okay Robin says there is no
stick I'm on the website there's
literally a stick on here yeah there's
mix and match three stick pack minted
cucumber toasted coconut lavender Sage
Colony Road peony rose on scented
pea-sized
Tangerine yeah there's all these sticks
in here they got sticks they got creams
they got wipes they got bundles yeah
solid deodorant there's green deodorant
it's it's a um
it's a whole package type thing yeah
this is interesting never heard of this
stuff never heard of this stuff the Lumi
the people that make the Lumi they also
have a um a specific man's product I
believe oh um
I think it's called something different
or maybe it goes by a different name I
mean yeah but I think it's the same it's
the same it's the same lady
it's there and she makes the um she
makes the that's the one they advertised
all the way at the bottom four men Mando
Mando Mando Nando oh like okay deodorant
Mando okay
deodorant you know bourbon leather I
don't know if I want to smell like
bourbon leather you don't want your
balls to smell like leather no Mount
Fuji bourbon leather I mean just give me
a [__] regular scent man you know
give me that Ocean Spray [__] Ocean
Spray balls whatever whatever those main
ones are you want your you want your
ball sack to smell like you've been
surfing do you want your ball sack to
smell like [__] Urban leather yeah
you're like Whoa man it looks like you
look at this in a barrel look at this
saddle bag here I'm fine with more of
like a no scent or like a cologne type
of scent but like bourbon leather
reminds me of the people that wear like
those those novelty scents where you're
like oh it smells like you were just
smoking a a cigar in a you know like you
just walked out of a fumador kind of
thing there's those weird novelty ones
I'm not really into those I feel like
they're too like just do the thing man I
don't need all these extra cents on me
you know so but I'm a simple man I'm a
simple man what's simple taste so you
don't like the um you don't like the
like um
like the the natural smells right like
like green tree oh Pine is fine like the
pine the the sport ones the ocean spray
mist or whatever those are totally fine
but once you get into these weird ones
like [__] bourbon leather and it
smells like whiskey and all this [__]
I'm like that's a little too
you can do that that's fine but for me
I'm just like I don't need that extra I
don't need an additional smell that
makes it smell like I was
in something else you know all right
okay well that's what I gotta say but if
they want I mean hey look I'll do the
I'll I'll do the I'll do the read if
they wanna they wanna that's right I'm
gonna I'm gonna reach out to him yeah
I'm seriously gonna reach out to him I
mean you know we know clearly from this
conversation right now that you have
swamp ass well I mean not right now I
mean there's been times on the show I'm
not gonna lie though I've been sitting
here you know and I've had swamp ass or
I had like chili the night before and it
would be nice to have something to
dampen the smell I'm just if I if I you
know not to not to segue into something
else but I would say if there was a
group of people that really did need
like a full body deodorant like right
something like this it would probably be
people within the Republican party man
they [__] stink the high heaven man
they smell like fascism you think
there's a um you think there's a um a
deodorant out there that could hide and
mask the smell of fashion or just
eliminate it all together maybe we
should consider
it does the reverse effect right because
you don't want to hide it you want to
bring it to the surf you want to you
want people to know when they walk oh
[__] that's a [__] fascist that's a
Nazi damn that guy smells like a goddamn
Nazi throw that in the garden I think I
think what we should do is we should
make deodorant that works with the
pheromones of a Nazi or a fascist so
that when you're walking down the street
or you're interacting with people in
public you know exactly how to identify
them because I don't want to hide I
don't want to hide the smell I want to
know exactly who to avoid I want to call
out Point them out
um Sage points out a good pointer on
YouTube you don't get the [__] coverage
on tyt you're not gonna get t-yd to talk
about planets you're kidding me you're
not gonna get this kind of content over
on dyt nor are you gonna get this kind
of content what was that this is your
brand new episode of what was it let's
play this and uh how long is this 11
minutes well
be right back as soon as what was that
here it is the brand new what was that I
want everyone to have fun tonight but
please be safe
if you find yourself disoriented or
confused it's either you're drunk or
Marjorie Taylor green wait what was that
find yourself disoriented or confused
it's either you're drunk or Marjorie
Taylor green President Joe Biden and
comedian Roy Wood Jr teamed up to roast
Fox News Clarence Thomas Marjorie Taylor
green and the rest of the Republican
party at the White House Correspondents
dinner and it did not disappoint it also
goes to show you an overall theme of how
Republicans are terrible at comedy
[Music]
the White House correspondence Center is
traditionally held to celebrate the
relationship between the White House and
the media and to raise money for
scholarships that support aspiring
journalists and I'd like to stop right
now and congratulate tonight's top
scholarship recipient Arizona State
senior George Santos
[Laughter]
oh yeah George couldn't be here today
he's auditioning for Rupaul's Drag Race
yeah we say good luck to you George
that was the only joke about George
Sanchez throughout the whole night which
is a bit awkward when you realize that
Santo's cooked up this lie before the
dinner so I've been made aware on good
authority that I will be the number one
topic of roasting tonight at the White
House correspondent Center sorry George
but you weren't the main course at this
dinner you were just a side dish that
nobody ordered anyway the correspondence
Center also serves as an opportunity for
the president to poke fun at himself and
his administration as well as the media
and other politicians in a lighthearted
and comedic way well not everybody loves
NPR
Elon Musk tweeted that it should be
defunded
well the best way to make NPR go away
sriilla must to buy it
I'm Jonathan finiak with Wyoming LLC
attorney we can assist you with
everything but a major difference
between Democrats and Republicans is
their ability to take a joke especially
one that is self-deprecating you might
think I don't like River Murdoch that's
simply not true
How could a dislike a guy who makes me
look like Harry Styles
call me old
I call it being seasoned
you say I'm ancient
I say I'm wise
the same over the hill
Don Lemon would say that's a man in his
prime
however Republicans seem to think that
jokes about them at this event are
personal attacks I'll give you an
example here's Donald Trump getting
roasted during the 2011 correspondent
Center Donald Trump has been saying that
he will run for president as a
republican which is surprising since I
just assumed he was running as a joke
Donald Trump often appears on Fox which
is ironic because a fox often appears on
Donald Trump's head
Trump and you can't finish your entree
don't worry the fox will eat it
it's been 12 years and the pouty face
that Trump gave Seth Meyers never gets
old and it definitely didn't help when
Obama made fun of Trump no one is
happier no one is prouder
to put this birth certificate matter to
rest than the Donald
and that's because he can finally get
back to focusing on the issues that
matter
like
did we fake the moon landing
all kidding aside obviously we all know
about your credentials and breadth of
experience
um
recently in an episode of Celebrity
Apprentice
at the steakhouse
the men's cooking team uh did not
impress the judges from Omaha Steaks
and there was a lot of blame to go
around but you Mr Trump recognized that
the real problem was a lack of
leadership
and so ultimately you didn't blame
Little John or meatloaf
you fired Gary Busey
and these are the kind of decisions that
would keep me up at night say what you
will about uh Mr Trump he certainly
would bring some change to the White
House
I mean it's only fair considering how
much Trump pushed the Obama birther
conspiracy but just for good measure
here's Obama roasting him again in 2012.
last year at this time in fact on this
very weekend
we finally delivered Justice to one of
the world's most notorious individuals
[Applause]
calm down it's just a joke you
snowflakes I mean I'm just repeating
what Republicans say to other people
they offend the only difference is their
jokes are usually sexist and or racist
but when it comes to Trump he was so
humiliated during the 2011 dinner that
he never came back in fact Trump is so
afraid of being laughed at that in 2017
he became the first president in decades
to not attend and then refused to show
up for the dinner during his entire time
in the White House the last time a
sitting president didn't attend the
dinner was Ronald Reagan in 1981 and
that was only because he was recovering
from being shot after an assassination
attempt who knows maybe if Trump learned
to laugh at himself he wouldn't be so
stressed out in attacking reporters on
his plane but seriously laughing at
herself is actually tied to great
leadership which explains why Trump and
the Republican Party are so bad at it
one of the highlights in the night had
to be when Biden brought up Tucker
Carlson Fox news's former resident white
supremacist
the other one is underestimating me and
Kamala
well the truth is
we really have a record to be proud of
vaccinated the nation
transformed the economy
earned historic legislative victories
and Midterm results
but the job isn't finished
I mean
it is finished for Tucker Carlson
[Applause]
what do you warning about like that
give me a break
Republicans love to dish it out but they
can never take it ever just look back at
the 2018 correspondence Center we're
committee Michelle wolf roasted Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and of course we have
Sarah Huckabee Sanders we are graced
with Sarah's presence tonight I have to
say I'm a little star struck I love you
as Aunt Lydia in the handmaid's tale and
I'm never really sure what to call Sarah
Huckabee Sanders you know is it Sarah
Sanders is it Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
it cousin Huckabee is it Auntie Huckabee
Sanders like what's Uncle Tom but for
white women who disappoint other white
women
Coulter
I actually really like Sarah I think
she's very resourceful like she Burns
facts and then she uses that Ash to
create a perfect smokey eye
like maybe she's born with it maybe it's
lies apparently Republicans think jokes
about smokey eye Sanders are very
offensive but old race is Trump
attacking people on Twitter is totally
fine but then again what do you expect
when your party is built on fear anger
and hatred it's really hard to find the
funny but the real reasons that
Republicans are scared of Comedy is that
they know that deep down their policies
are a joke I mean just take a look at
the recent record they tried to repeal
Obamacare without a replacement they got
taxes for the rich and left the rest of
us to put the bill and they've been
stripping away lgbtq plus and women's
rights at every turn and it's not just
our policies that are joke it's that
they're better telling jokes themselves
remember when Ted Cruz kept trying to
make fun of pronouns well I'm Ted Cruz
and my pronoun is kiss my Republicans
love that unoriginal joke so much that
they use it every chance they get even
washed up comedian Roseanne Barr my
pronouns are kiss my
if you ask me Republicans spend so much
time in their own Echo chamber that they
forget what a sense of humor sounds like
their humor pretty much consists of them
trying to own the libs which inevitably
turns into them being the butt of the
joke create the cable news and networks
are here tonight
MSNBC on by NBC Universal
Fox News owned by Dominion voting
systems
hi it's Rochelle let your home Blossom
during our spring care stand sale
[Applause]
last year
his favorite Fox movie Porter is able to
attend because they were fully
vaccinated and boosted
this year
with that 787 million dollar settlement
they're here because they couldn't say
no to a free meal
and how
I'd call Fox honest fair and truthful
then I could be sued for defamation
Fox News is like the onion but without
the self-awareness to be honest
Republicans kind of remind me of
Sideshow Bob repeatedly stepping on
rakes
[Music]
and the reason these jokes are so
effective at triggering Republicans is
because they're built on truth and they
don't like getting called out in a room
full of people especially one that's
being recorded and also speaking of drag
queens can we stop with the groom and
stuff can you stop talking about the
drag queens are not at a school to groom
your kids
stop it
and even if they were most of them kids
gonna get shot at school it ain't no
problem
don't grown past legislation
[Applause]
I think boom is gonna bother me I'm like
I'm like Mitch McConnell I ain't got no
soul and before I go I just wanted to
highlight this beautifully crafted joke
about Justice Clarence Thomas
billionaire named Harlan Crowe
flying Clarence Thomas all over the
world on unreported trips like the
Instagram model taking plans
to the Maldives and the beaches and all
they paid for his mama's house this
billion I paid for care homes mama's
house
I Gotta Give It Up to billionaires
billionaires boy y'all y'all look
Relentless y'all always come up with
something new to buy
like just when you think of everything
you could buy on earth a billionaire
will come up with a new thing y'all by
space Rockets you bought Twitter
this man bought a Supreme Court Justice
do you understand how rich you have to
be to buy a supreme a black one on top
of that
there's only two in stock
and Harlan Pro owns half the inventory
we can all see Clarence Thomas
but he belongs to billionaire Harlan
Crowe
and that's what an nft is so let's give
it up for President Joe Biden and
comedian Roy Wood Jr who proved that
even in the midst of a divided country
laughter is still the best medicine so
until next episode I'm Gabe Sanchez and
this has been what was that if you
enjoyed today's episode and want to
support the work that goes into creating
the what was that show you can join my
patreon at whatwizthatchow.com you'll
get access to early episodes exclusive
bits behind the scenes content access to
the show's private Discord as well as
live q and A's to connect directly with
me to offer up comments questions and
suggested topics to be featured on the
show thanks again for watching and I
hope to see you over on patreon
there you go what was that what was that
with a few commercials peppered in there
you're still muted and you're on mute
still muted yeah I saw people ask what
the commercial was that was a commercial
on Tony's end it's you know what what am
I gonna do all right no I know my
monetized version no I mean that's what
it is send me the link I gotta you gotta
send an unlisted link from now on I
guess
um that way it won't have the
commercials in there gotcha got it
anyways that great job on the what was
that what's I I tell you um I I bet it
was actually because usually when you're
doing these what was that you got to go
watch like horrendous Clips right yeah
yeah oh my God but this one you're like
you gotta go watch all the other
correspondence dinners yeah it was
actually a lot of fun I mean like a lot
of it too A lot of it too was uh like
because I usually watch the
correspondence centers over the past
years and I knew exactly which ones I
was like oh I gotta go back to 2011. I
got to go to 2012. I gotta go to 2017
you know those are the ones that really
matter I could go earlier but these are
the ones that play in into this whole
idea of Republicans not being able to
take jokes and also you know always
always gotta I do a dig at Trump when I
can
well speaking of digging at Trump
he kind of is digging at himself right
like have you watched these I haven't
watched any of them Apes oh my God you
haven't seen any of this now you've read
some of it right yeah I've read a little
bit yeah yeah I haven't watched any yet
you're on a delay again what the hell
did you do damn it man yeah let's see
here I'm gonna let me go back out all
right go back out come back in uh I'm
gonna I'm gonna get some of this um
there's one out there that's really long
man it's like a four minute [__]
um video but I'm gonna show you guys
some of these tapes and depositions now
again we've watched we've watched as
um
we've seen the scripts come out right uh
the the transcripts of this deposition
and we knew he was saying some dumb [__]
but I mean it's nothing like watching
this ass wipe do this right it's nothing
like watching this [__] just
absolutely make a fool out of himself
now again this is
um this one here is from October 19
2022.
and this guy he just
I can't even believe after watching this
that some people like yeah that's he's
the greatest president of all time and
he's the reason why we're we're gonna
save America or some [__] right like
what this is this is their guy that's
supposed to stand in for for Jesus
Christ the Republican Jesus
this is really wild [__] now let's see
if we can get Gabe back in here uh you
know what and well we'll just go to the
tape and we'll replay it it ain't that
long listen to what he says about
grabbing women by the [__] and his
argument of why he grabs women by the
[__] Gabe Sanchez this is where he's
gonna talk about how he's entitled
fortunately or unfortunately to grab
women by the [__] this is this is wild
[__] watch this and you say and again
this has become very famous in this
video
I just start kissing them it's like a
magnet just kiss I don't even wait
and when you're a star they let you do
it you can do anything grab them by the
[__] you could do anything that's what
you said girl well historically that's
true with stars
does he mean like
in history white men white powerful men
can sexually assault women and get away
with it is that what he that's it sounds
like it sounds like him I mean what he's
doing is he's justifying this moment to
be like well I mean historically other
white men have done that so why can't I
right no one had a problem with it
before it's like
it's not that no one had a problem with
it it's that rich or powerful men of
authority were able to get away with it
because they had influence they could
yeah what the [__] so so you're at
someone's saying fortunately I'm saying
he says yeah yeah yeah
I'm not saying fortunately listen listen
the other thing about this is well let
me let me just play this part it's
[__] wild [__] that he that his brain
tells him this stuff listen
that they can grab women by the [__]
well that's what it's if you look over
the last million years I guess
million years what is he talking about
what
he okay so either he thinks right that
like Hollywood stars have been around
for a million years or he doesn't know
that humans
haven't even does he know I don't know
if he does he is he aware can I
oh this this guy was in charge of our
country folks this guy had the nuclear
codes in his pocket god damn it I'm
gonna have to do a what was that on this
[__] thing what the [__] okay so
let's let's continue here this is I mean
these clips don't get any better they
get worse but listen yes that's been
largely true not always but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately there it is
and you consider yourself uh to be a
star
the base the base look
okay I just want to point out this is
October of last year right 19.
um and I also want to point out is his
hair getting worse and worse because it
looks like [__] in this video right I
mean it always looks like [__] but look
at it it it's kind of like jihad's got
like this it's a weird shape up here do
you see yeah yeah am I just being an
[__] here or I mean no it's just I
don't think these depositions are uh are
great great lighting or uh right
or just you know because he's in these
for hours right like how many hours is
he in this deposition for
um it was a long time multiple right
five seven or something right it's it's
[__] crazy [__] like this is I even
so now I had to [__] look this up to
figure out when the first human existed
right yeah so okay two million years ago
it says the first human ancestors
appeared between five million and seven
million probably when they were ape-like
creatures in Africa began to walk right
they don't look like us
no no then some of them spread into
Africa Asia Europe over the two million
years ago uh when did he first around
two million years ago is when they first
evolved but a million years ago we had
[__] stars and celebrities what the
[__] is he talking about man what is
what I don't know I mean a million years
ago you know how long it like [__]
you know how long it took you to travel
okay the only people who were like stars
and celebrities were people who were
like pillaging Villages right it was
like Villages they were they were the
ones clubbing people in the cave
so I mean if that's is that what he's
talking about like we're cavemen and I
mean let's what in the [__] this is I
mean
I can't even tell you I'm trying to
think of like when the most famous like
the famous people like Genghis Khan
Genghis Khan was around let's see when
uh 1162 to 12 27.
that's not a million years ago I'm
trying to think of like the most famous
people in existence I don't know Greek
mythology right right but if I look at
these people like I'm trying to think of
people who like uh you know you'd be
like oh Genghis Khan he was a [__]
you know he he was someone who went out
and and uh an attacked and expanded his
Empire and like you know like you're
thinking like Napoleon Genghis Khan like
these are all people you think about but
that's in like the last [__] couple
thousand years right
well like the idea
thousand million you know who's counting
but a million years this is when was
Hollywood California when was Hollywood
California chartered
no I mean before talking about Hollywood
it was like Holly it had a different
name stars stars if you're talking about
Hollywood Hollywood California
incorporated
1903.
it's almost a million it's almost yeah I
mean if you think about it it's getting
there somehow we went from
uh a hundred and so years ten years
that's a million millions of years okay
what the [__] let's watch this where he
disparages
um and he I think he's gonna watch a
video of himself on stage here and then
he has to he has to uh respond to it
let's watch it when you said in that
video that misleads would not be your
first choice
you were referring to her physical looks
correct just the overall not I I look at
her I see her I hear what she says
whatever you wouldn't be a choice of
mine either
I would not under any circumstances have
any interest in you what so he's like
parties you got you gotta remember this
is all under
questioning of rather you you would
sexually assault and rape someone he's
like look I wouldn't sexually assault
and rape you
what God damn I hope not like what the
[__] dude I'm telling this is some wild
[__] man he's like hey would you do it
he's like look I mean if I'm being
honest and I'm being honest right now I
don't find you attractive so I wouldn't
rape you and that's like whoa whoa why
I want to know I want to know who he
directed that app do you want to know
who says that
um
I mean like who was the who is the woman
that was questioning I know but I'm
saying oh yeah yeah the question who
would say that and and right the answer
is
someone who would rape somebody yeah oh
yeah would you be racist with the heart
somewhat around
whoosh yeah this guy okay let's keep
going there's several of these states
with um tapes Clips
what else he says here about the about
the person questioning
I'm honest when I say it uh she I would
not have any interest in when you said
it he's he's honest he's just he look
he's just he just he's like how can you
how can you attack me I'm being an
honest man you know I'm not being I'm
not insulting you I'm not insulting this
woman I wouldn't I wouldn't rape her
she's too ugly to rape what like that's
literally what he is saying in some of
these points uh let's see this is uh
um I'm trying to find the one where he
um here it is here it is this is the one
I think where he missed he he's looking
at a photo now this is the famous one
that we we got the transcript of oh
right yeah yeah where he was he
misidentifies
um Eugene Carroll in a picture and with
his wife right with his wife Marla well
our soon-to-be wife at the time but here
here's here's a clip of that I think so
yes and do you recall when you first saw
this photo
at some point during the process I saw
that's uh I guess her husband John
Johnson who
was an anchor
for ABC nice guy I thought I mean I
don't know him but I thought he was
pretty good at what he did
um
I don't even know who the woman let's
say I don't know who it's Marla
you say Marvel's in this photo
that's Marla yeah it's here
oh [__] the person you just pointed to
was oh
and the person the woman on the right is
your now you notice who interjects did
you notice who interjects
who says whoa whoa dummy that's not
that's not that was uh Elena Haber yes
yes Selena hamba Who interjects
Um there so let's finish this one up
then why I don't know this was the
picture I assume that's John Johnson is
that because it's very blurry
no
grandpa needs some [__] readers man
uh you can't see that picture when he's
holding it to his face it's blurry Gabe
it's blurry I can't tell the difference
between uh my wife my wife and also the
woman that uh that I rape and assaulted
you know it's well and and also to that
point I mean obviously if he isn't um a
sexually attracted enough to Eugene
Carroll to do what she's claiming he did
to her then he wouldn't be sexually
attracted to his wife either Marla
Maples right yeah I mean is that also I
mean like if let me uh hold on let me
find that image because I'm pretty sure
it's not blurry
right yeah see if you can find that
um that that that's the same one there
I'm trying to find
the other one
um where some other crazy [__] now the
best part about all this
the best part about this whole thing is
we're gonna have this for the general
election folks oh yeah
who doesn't believe that this entire
thing is going to be just racked up on
commercial after commercial Africa I
mean I would keep playing just that
[__] unfortunately of the men have
been who have been stars have been doing
this for a million years and also I
wouldn't rape you right just play that
okay so is any of this blurry
it doesn't look blurry to me just to
give you an idea of how how wide the
focus is you can see the guy that's all
the way in the back there
right you can pick out you can pick that
design the range of those of this field
in terms of where the photo was taken
who is this right here who is this
that's e Gene right mm-hmm
and he thought that was Marla Maples
there's my wife that's my wife my wife
and then Alina was like no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no hey
dummy that's not your wife that's e Gene
Carroll right she stops him in his
tracks
uh that that that let's see apparently
Howard Stern has uh made comment on this
uh the jury's gonna find him to be a
rapist Howard says
um worst deposition I've ever seen
um because they they hear the final the
final statements are today right closing
arguments yeah well he had till
yesterday at a certain time to to show
up and testify well because the judge
called this Bluff yeah yeah because
Trump's like yeah sure I might come you
know whatever the judge was like okay
you come by this date or you forfeit
your ability to appear and he forfeited
right because that's what a [__] ass
[__] does well uh can you see while I'm
playing this video can you see if you
can find there is a there's a video of
him playing golf where they're asking
him questions and he's answering he's
asking is being asked a question about
showing up and then at forfeiting his
right to even speak because this was the
[__] [__] that we got in the January
are the Insurrection impeachment right
where he's like oh we don't get to make
our case I don't get to make my case
which he had all the chance in the world
to go make his case in court but he
can't he can't because he'll get
destroyed and he'll destroy any chance
he has it appeals if he goes and and if
he went and did this
um he just uh chop it up with a [__]
ax but here's apparently Howard Stern's
take on the deposition let's listen I
still again I know you're gonna bash me
some of you in the audience I know there
are still trumpies out there
after you watch that deposition
like I don't know if you've ever been
deposed I have you kind of know to just
answer honestly and minimally
and they tell the Trump's got lawyers
and lawyers probably said hey Trump
just answer the [__] question
don't elaborate yes or no answers so I I
before we get too far in this because he
brings up a good point Have you ever
been to pose before
me personally yeah
uh no I've been in I've been in court
but I've never been deposed you've never
been to post so I so I've been in a
deposition like me being deposed and
being questioned and I had an attorney
there right and the attorney like
beforehand they they I mean they spend
you know 20 30 minutes kind of prepping
you before they're like hey I'm gonna be
sitting at the table and when they ask
the question make sure not to answer
right away don't just jump on the answer
think about it take a second to know
what the answer is because he said that
gives me time if I need to object to
enter to interject if I don't think that
the question is fair I don't put
anything on the record before I have a
chance to stop Zach well well I mean the
the thing is is that in the attorneys
are like if they frame up the question
in a certain way I may make them reframe
the question because they're trying
they're trying to get a certain answer
out of you and I have the ability and
and we have the right to ask them to
reframe a question if I can see where
this is going because an attorney not
only
um represents someone who is being
deposed but attorneys give depositions
right they're trained in this art form
to depose someone else so an attorney
who is defending someone or there to
represent them a being deposed well see
we'll see maybe something coming that
the person who's being deposed won't see
and that's how they prep you they'll
tell you you know don't just answer
right away take a minute and and
Howard's right they'll say look only
answered with this few words as you
possibly can yes no is fine if you don't
know something say I don't know and I
will interject for them to reframe the
question if they need to know this
information and and if you don't know
how to get to a point then then the
attorney will help like they guide you
through this right when you have a
representative now a lot of people
aren't [__] afforded or represented
because they can't afford an attorney
but Howard's right this [__] like
literally this do you know how many how
many times has Trump been deposed can
you look that up to see how many times
he's actually been deposed you would
think that this [__] [__] would be
an expert at being deposed by now but it
is clear in this deposition he is
nowhere near an expert of anything he's
a [__] bonehead as our [__]
thumbnail said today what a [__]
bonehead because again you would think
that he would almost be a professional
at this but he's not so let's finish
Howard's little thing here while you're
looking for how many times Trump's been
deposed in his life
and he's I mean
he wants to be perceived as a smart guy
he [__] up that deposition so bad
they'll probably I think the jury's
gonna find him to be a rapist that's
what I think
I mean he [__] that thing so so the
the the lawyer goes it's a slam dunk
what you say the lawyer goes hey didn't
you say on the Access Hollywood tape
that um you can grab Girls by the [__]
he goes yes I said that okay it's honest
he goes but as soon as he says but
like again again you don't elaborate and
and and really uh why wouldn't like in
that moment why wouldn't Elena have his
like hold his arm be like hey
like look at him make eye contact and be
like
because you don't see you don't see
Alina unless she leans over right so
it's like off camera she could be like
that's the other thing that I remember
about my deposition
um is that my attorney was sitting at
the table and he said I'm gonna be I'm
gonna make sure my hands are in plain
sight of you and he said I will have my
hands on the table and if I want you to
stop I will I will start to raise my
hand
and and that is your signal to pause for
a minute so I can clarify what's going
on because I don't want this person to
get you in this situation where you're
saying more things than you need than
the question they're asking and he and
again Howard's right like you just say
yeah that's what I said in the tape
because he can't dispute that yeah
that's what I said in the tape why'd you
say it in the tape I went over this in
public I said it in a in in the debate
with Hillary Clinton that right that's
my reasoning like again you don't have
to go but I would grab him by the [__]
if they were good looking up if they're
not good looking enough I wouldn't and
eating Carol just isn't good looking
enough because she's claiming that's
literally that's what that is exactly
what Eugene Caro is claiming he did is
he grabbed her and stuck his hand inside
of her like he raped her yeah and and
and it's it's hilarious that he can't
even see that that is
his bone-headedry
is going to get him in trouble here and
really you know I think
to be
complete 100 about it here's the thing I
don't think I think Eugene Carroll is
probably going to win this to some
degree yeah yeah I don't know how much
they're gonna order even if they award
or one dollar it's gonna take years and
years and years to milk one dollar out
of this but it doesn't matter right
doesn't matter doesn't matter how much
she gets it's the fact that he was
trying guilty to some degree of raping
eging Carol because right now again it's
one of those things that's like that
[__] ad just made itself right do you
want to have a president who rapes women
right well the other thing too is that I
think even more because if each and
Carol really was about the money she'd
have settled this a long time ago Donald
Trump put a rotor check she'd went a
better way and he would have said e Gene
Carroll and
she she admitted she was wrong or
whatever the hell
is the case and he'd still be
disparaging her and but it's not about
the money to eating Carol you can tell
it's about her truth which is the most
important thing here is her truth right
in this trial and I think
um broadly
um in our in our culture and in our
discourse right now I think the most
important thing if he is found guilty I
think really it gives the ability for
Americans to go well
they will hold someone accountable like
it's it's possible that they hold
someone accountable it's kind of like
after the Alex Jones trial a lot of
people are like wow that because that
was really the the stepping stone for
the defamation case of dominion against
Fox News it really truly was the
starting of the stepping stone that hey
you can't you can't just make [__] up
knowing that it's lies right if if you
are defaming on purpose it is
intentional and you have malice yeah
you're [__] liable for it so uh Biff
teal asked a question yeah uh or or Theo
I don't know if I'm pronouncing it right
teal or Theo but
um it's a good question right like if
he's found guilty does he have to
register as a sex offender I don't think
so because it's not a criminal case it's
a civil case and technically I don't
think the jury actually has to find him
guilty of raping her I just think they
have to find that um his dad defamation
of her is very credible in other words
in other words so they I and I think you
know I'm not really sure but I mean now
people can be like well yeah but also it
can go you know
this means that legally right it
wouldn't be defamation if someone were
to run an ad and be like Donald Trump
known rapist right well I mean that's
that's the problem that he's gonna have
here and I think the other
um problem that the Republican party has
in this discourse
is that he's being held accountable and
he can be held accountable and it's not
the end of the Earth it's not it's not
going to be that big of a deal if
someone's held accountable for their
[__] actions which includes the
felonies in New York it includes
whatever felonies he's got coming in
Georgia whenever a felon he's got coming
with Jack Smith because folks I I know I
know it feels like this is a slow roll
uh to accountability for Trump but all
this is going to come crashing down on
him all at once yeah I mean typically
what happens is we see other people
within the Republican Party who are like
oh you guys are all groomers and [__]
sex traffickers and rapists all stuff
and then you find those people that were
just clearly projecting their own crimes
uh or known crimes uh from like or
crimes from known like you know
Affiliates or or people that they're uh
connected with right and this is one
where it's like you have someone who's
running for the highest office in the
land and he's now a rapist so now now
you have the Republican Party be like
all right you guys are now known rapist
supporters you guys [__] support
rapists you guys are fan of rapists you
won't speak out and condemn the acts
that he uh that he took right
they're gonna try and play it down and
be like oh this was [__] uh this was
a hoax or this was a [__] Witch Hunt
this was unfair blah blah all this
[__] but at the end of the day it's
like it's like look dude we got a guy
running for office to be president who
has now been legally you know found to
be uh raping at least one woman right
there are other women who have who have
come forward 26 or so women that have
come forward to say that Trump sexually
assaulted them but this is the first one
where we have
an actual a civil uh or or at least uh
some sort of resolve uh that happens in
a in a case right everything else has
been like an allegation or an accusation
or you know something like that right
but it's never gone this far this is the
furthest that it's in Tom on YouTube ask
uh how is rape a civil tribe because
it's a defamation case against the claim
that e Gene Carroll leveled against
Donald Trump which is rape and he's
defaming her she's claiming he's
defaming her which I mean we're gonna
see the result in the jury
I would say this week we're going to get
a result of what this is going to be if
we don't already uh have one sometimes
because the case is he's saying that
she's lying
right she's making it up which by
default if you're saying Trump raped me
right and he's saying I never raped her
she's a liar she's crazy she's making
[__] up right
and well and and the fact is because the
really the Crux of the argument here is
and really it's because Trump doesn't
have that uh any good attorneys around
him the the argument of defamation is is
that he's saying she's not she's not
good looking enough for him to rape her
like literally he's saying that so he's
saying my defense is I wouldn't rape her
because she's ugly but the problem is
that he has is the things that he said
in the past about her and other women
and and some of the evidence like in the
photo and then the deposition where he's
like yeah that's my wife Marla yeah whoa
whoa so your wife is too ugly is that
what you're saying because it feels like
that's what you're kind of saying but he
doesn't really know what he's saying
folks he doesn't know because this guy
is such a [__] pathological liar that
he doesn't know where reality begins and
where re in [__] fiction begins
listen to this this is in response to
the judge giving an ultimatum you either
show up by this time and date which was
yesterday I believe sometime yesterday
it was like 5 p.m yeah something like
that eastern time I believe if you
either show up yesterday or you're done
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna hold this
court any longer for you to [__] play
your stupid game and here's what's his
response on the golf course I
Ireland and I have to leave Scotland
where I have great properties I have to
leave early
I don't have to but I choose to will you
attend the trial Mr President
it's a disgrace
against a rich guy
or in my case against
a famous rich and political person
okay all right so let me let me ask you
give stitches if you had to describe
Donald Trump in three words would it be
rich famous
political
it would be not like those were never
the things that came for we know he's
not rich he's definitely not political
what was the other one
famous I mean he's Infamous yeah he's
Infamous I'd say he's Infamous how
Infamous uh uh creepy and
um I would say that I don't know slimy
um there's all kinds of words you could
use you know what's funny about this
he's so [__] upset that he's in
Ireland and the judge is like hey come
here and be in your trial or don't yeah
I don't give it you can take a flight
dude two you can [__] land in New
York we'll do it here you show up you
[__] say what you want to say
and don't [__] [__] and moan about
it anymore man right you know and the
whole idea that he's standing there
saying on his golf course in Ireland
where he it's his I had to agree here I
had to be here I couldn't show up right
well he has great properties and great
golf course he owns these things he's a
rich person and how the Trump supporters
aren't like
this guy is an elitist I mean you keep
yelling and screaming about the elite
lying to you what do you [__] think
this is watch that's leading the polls
by 40 points and I have to go back for a
woman that made a false accusation about
me and I have a judge who's extremely
hostile and I'm gonna go back and I'm
gonna confront this with this woman is a
disgrace and it shouldn't be allowed to
happen in our country you became that's
totally false it was fake she's a fake
she wrote it a book she's a Democrat
we have a rough judge we have a judge
that doesn't like very much appointed by
Bill Clinton
he said he's a guy that doesn't like me
much I guess not allowing the coach that
they wanted to put into evidence once we
said yes put it into evidence they said
oh we don't want to do that it's a
disgrace
but I have to do it that's part of life
that's part of life when you when you
rape someone you sexually assault
someone and you have to pay and you have
to be held accountable in a civil suit
because you defame that person you know
what you should do you should fly to
Ireland to your golf course here's
advice for anyone out there that gets in
this situation you should fly to your
golf course that you own in Ireland and
you should stand there complaining about
how rich you are and about how famous
you are and how they can't do this to
you because you're rich and famous you
should be grabbing them by the [__] and
oh by the way while I'm airing my
grievances I want to tell you that I'm
going to defame her right here on the
spot like what the [__] are you doing
like dude the guy needs to shut the [__]
up no no no no no no no no no no totally
totally like if are here
people who are watching this Spectators
yeah man [__] say everything you want
get it out
you feel like you're [__] exonerating
yourself from this crime and you're like
guys I'm the victim and the only way for
me to to show you I'm the victim is to
[__] on the person that's called that's
calling me a liar right right and uh to
so it's like totally do it but if I was
a lawyer I'd be [__] on speed
doubling shut the [__] up right how how
hasn't his attorney sat down with him
and like look well we know it's not a
Lena habit anymore someone else who's
running this one but also Barbara uh
Barbara Ben Stein
um says
uh uh his golf course in Scotland the
future plot of his current wife
are you serious no way I mean does he
have like a does he have like a spot at
the seventh green yeah he's probably got
a spot over there it's like do not
disturb and people are like what's that
rectangular plot for he goes in the
ditch somewhere like nothing yeah like
he [__] buried his first wife in a
ditch
she's like oh he's like see this sand
trap over here yeah we're gonna cover it
over in a little bit it's gonna be a new
plot for someone else but we'll have a
little plaque on the ground it'll be
great it'll be great
you know I was gonna
um show these uh videos
of Allen Texas and I don't mean to
um segue so quickly and these grotesque
images but they're they're deleting them
in Mass off Twitter it looks like is
that what you're finding too yeah I saw
some people that were commenting the
photos and I was like oh like because so
I was out of town this weekend and I was
like sparsely getting
reception right and following up on the
updates when I could and I was like oh
man this is [__] crazy and I did see
some photos before they were deleted or
at least they were removed for Community
guideline violations
God damn I say I say everyone should see
these photos everyone should listen yeah
I mean show those I mean if you
I feel I don't know I I feel torn
because obviously like out of respect
out of the families but I'm sure those
families who lost their family members
would want like are willing to go to the
extreme right and are willing to to show
the [__] just
that
the inhumanity that that that is shown
the policies of these politicians the
idea that people [__] their faces
were blast off [__] man
[__] up dude so there's an interview
of one of the First Responders and um I
don't know if I have time to play that
today because I want to play the um uh
State Rep Gene Wu
um in Texas
uh who is speaking this morning
in Austin
um but he the the first responder talks
about goes on CNN where he rushed to the
scene after the shooter kind of moved
away from where the original firing
happened
um
and he rushed to try to help the people
who were injured and the first person he
came to was deceased the second person
he moved on he was trying to do triage
obviously he's
um a foreign police officer I think he's
a former military uh personnel and um so
he's trained in some sort of Battlefield
triage moved on to the next person and
it was a woman crouched down in the bush
with her hands over her face and he
describes how he um turned her over to
check her pulse and when he moved her
hands away from her face she did not
have one because it was [__] blown
off she did not have a face that's what
these guns do and when they hit your
flesh as they rip it apart at salty
Sylvester on Twitch says be careful Tony
twitch terms of service yeah I've
considered this I've thought about it
all weekend I've been thinking about it
the entire time uh up until right now
rather I want to show these images or
not on the show I think it's important
for everyone to see him
um I I'm probably not going to at this
point we I may do it in some
um in some form or fashion eventually
just because they'll shut this show down
um not only not only will the platform
shut shut it down but some of our
Partnerships will probably shut it down
and I don't know that it'll do the
audience very much good I do encourage
you though and I know it's grotesque and
I know it it'll make your stomach turn
to go look at these videos and these
images but don't look away this is what
this is the result
what the [__] the policies that we have
in these states are causing you know
this is what is the result of it I I
think
um because again like you know I you
know it's completely up to the families
in in showing them respect right how
much they're willing to expose that type
of inhumanity in that type of
slaughtering that was done to their
family members right and I do think
there's some to be learned from Emmett
Till right like that's something you
know we have a history that in Chicago
and it was something that was very
effective it was rough to see right for
what those guys did to Emmett Till but
it was necessary to to sh to put a face
on that crime it wasn't just like oh
here's something that written about in
the in the paper here's just a stat or
whatever it's actually humanizing
the inhumanity that was done right to
these people who didn't deserve it
and I would say
and the re and the reason I I would I am
I am
in support of showing them is because
you have people who say they're pro-life
right these anti-abortion pro-life I'm
gonna go [__] stand outside a Planned
Parenthood that offers way more services
than just an abortion right
and they have their their [__]
protest [__] and they're like ah look at
these babies look at they kill these
babies look at this inhumanity okay fine
okay fine let's do the same thing right
put that on [__] poster boards with
[__] picket sticks and go around and
say look at the debts and the murdering
of innocent children innocent people
family members you say you're pro-life
but you're willing to just say oh
thoughts and prayers and move on to the
next one right okay so I I'm I'm gonna
make the decision here because the
audience is talking about it a lot here
in the chat and um I respect the
audience I respect you guys and I know
if you want to see them and if you're
hearing my voice you should go look at
them even if you don't want to
um just for the reason that Gabe is
saying is that look you have to feel the
impact of what is happening
this is not just something that you can
that you can say well I can imagine what
it would be no I'm telling you this is
some gory [__] and it is not like movie
gore it is saddening it is vile that
that
and here's what I want to tell you
Greg Abbott that [__] piece of trash
saw
crime scene footage videos pictures of
Uvaldi
of those children who ripped apart
their bodies mangled
by a weapon of war and close range in
that classroom that [__] has
seen those pictures
and he still to this day does not affect
him at all
because money from the gun lobby in the
NRA is more effective
than any inhumane
vile pictures that he would see of
little children being killed and the
only reason why these images and now in
Texas are so effective
it's because there's a little child
laying on the sidewalk
with their face blown off and their head
and their brains all over the sidewalk
and yeah is it grotesque to say but what
the [__] else do you want me to say what
what else how else are we going to
handle the truth the truth is that no
one no one in this country needs a
weapon that will do that to a child no
one I don't give a [__] who who you are
what tyrannical government you think
you're defending from you delusional
mind [__] little sheep
and and and again we should know what
this is we should know what the
consequences of our actions are and our
actions is to keep these people in power
and the way we keep them at Powers we
say nothing we capitulate
to this idea that we it won't happen to
us I won't have to look at the image I
won't have to deal with dead bodies
laying around me
and it's not the reality anymore this is
not reality we live in a reality where
yes you are going to be a you are going
to be within that listening distance or
you're gonna have to dodge bullets at
some point in this country that's just
where we're going
um old dirty Dasher
ask where can I find the pictures
um they're deleting them like crazy on
on Twitter but I'm sure people are still
going to be posting them and if you
really want to see them if you really
want to see the videos my suggestion is
go to Twitter
um search Alan
a-l-l-e-n that's the town Allen and our
Allen Texas and just hit the video tab
um and you'll probably run into them uh
there's a lot of censored videos on
Twitter too but do not watch the
censored ones that that's you're not
doing yourself any good and the reason
why is because when you talk to someone
when you say to someone I've seen the
images of a child having their [__]
face blown off in Allen Texas for what
so you can see you can feel good and
tough and feel like you have a really
big dick or something I don't understand
what there is nothing in that photo that
that is the justification for a right or
Freedom nothing not a goddamn thing
there's nothing to trade away for those
people's lives in those photos no
freedom
of anyone getting any gun anytime they
want wherever they want without a
background check without without nothing
it's a [__] lie it's a lie it's a lie
it's a lie
and until you look at the photos you
won't know the impact I'm telling you
you can't imagine the impact that it'll
have
um so if you want to see him my
suggestion is go to Twitter you don't
even have to have a Twitter account to
go to Twitter just go to twitter.com and
you can search Allen Texas and it'll
show the post you won't be able to
interact with it but you'll be able to
[__] see them you'll be able to see
them
um here is uh here's this clip I want to
play
in Austin today
the representative there the State Rep
Gene Wu and he's talking about
um doing something in Texas and we know
Texas is
the reason why is because they're one of
the states where anyone can get a gun
anytime they want there's no rules no
regulations they buy it one minute use
it the next that's just it's the [__]
the wild west was safer to be if you
want to know the honest truth I was
going to say it was the wild west but
the wild west was actually safer than
Texas right now let's listen and to
State Rep who the people who are
responsible
send their thoughts and prayers to God
and God has sent them
and no one is listening
to the people that God sent
what of what if oh my God
what a huge paradigm shift
to tell these [__] with their
thoughts and their prayers yes thoughts
and prayers they're here God is sending
you the answer to your thoughts and your
prayers [__] there's he's
sending you the answer all you got to do
is open your [__] ears and listen to
your thoughts to the answers to your
thoughts and prayers I mean it's like
what I said before you know after I've
honestly I forget which shooting it was
uh might have been Nashville I don't
know I mean it's hard to keep track
anymore man at the end of the day these
people that want to use their
Christianity and use their religious
bigotry and say oh thoughts and prayers
God's gonna have the answer it was all
for a specific reason and everything's
gonna be better for it well guess what
at the end of the day God the one who is
our father our creator the one who loves
us and will always forgive us
he is the one who let these children die
he is the one who let these innocent
people die he's the one who let that
shooter go to that mall and shoot those
people because they thought hey I'm
gonna go to the mall and go shopping I'm
gonna enjoy it with my family
again you can't go to a [__] Church a
synagogue a a an auditorium a movie
theater a grocery store a a Grade School
uh you can't go to a shopping mall none
of these places are safe and each of
these places even if it was a [__]
Presbyterian Church in Nashville
Tennessee even places that are under the
god under the guise of God under the
protection of God even those places
aren't safe
at the end of the day all of that
thoughts and prayers [__] can go get
[__] because at the end of the day God
let it happen and if anyone says oh God
it's all planned blah blah Divine shut
the [__] up man go [__] yourself go [__]
your thoughts and prayers and you can
get [__] lost because none of the
[__] that you say is ever doing anything
and there is always going to be these
people who are so cold-hearted despite
the fact that they say oh I love thy
neighbor and I want to save the children
and I want to be a Christian and I want
to care for you but won't lift a [__]
finger
a [__] finger they won't [__]
raise their [__] voice to say hey we
should pass legislation so that we can
actually protect these people that we
claim to love that we claim to want to
protect that we claim to want to [__]
save
all of those [__] I mean get [__]
lost man well the the thing is is that
their thoughts and prayers are so they
don't have to do anything right they
want to use it as an excuse to say oh
well I said thoughts and prayers so I'm
totally fine I did I did I know I said
my [__] our father I you know I I use
my rosary and I and I I [__] said a
Hail Mary yeah [__] right [__] man
well that's so they don't have to do
anything else like I don't know uh let's
try to solve the problem listen listen
to as representative Wu goes on here
we're gonna listen to the rest of this
you have prayed for an answer
you have begged for a solution
the solution is standing right here
your answer is looking you in the face
I Cry
because every time I see that [__]
video
to see those pictures
I see my son
there is no safe place in America
anymore
there's no church that's safe there is
no school that's safe there's no
shopping mall that's safe there's no
Library that's safe
not because of books not because of
trans kids who want Health Care
but because of things that people own
because we value
things over people
and I I don't know what to do anymore
at some point
the people blocking the laws
that could help prevent these type of
tragedies
at some point
they take some ownership of these
tragedies
no more please
please
pleading for lawmakers to do something
anything absolutely anything and and
that's
um and I don't mean to leave it on such
a dire note but folks I'm I'm asking the
audience
um
to do something and what I want you to
do is I want you to pick up the phone
today at least once once tomorrow maybe
once the next day and call your U.S
congressman call your United States
Center call your state center call your
state representative I don't care what
state you're in I don't I don't give a
[__]
um if your Senators Democrat Republican
and it's time to let them know and we
are sick and tired of this [__] and we
will not stop we will not stop talking
about this as long as people are getting
slaughtered I don't care if it's from
gang violence in streets I don't care if
it's in schools a private school a
public school a parochial school I don't
care if it's in a grocery store in
Buffalo or or if it's in the nightclub
in Orlando or if it's in uh I I just
don't give a [__] anymore our shopping
mall
wherever the [__] this is happening it's
it's got to stop and the only way is for
us to do something and to get loud and
yes
I tell you all the time I have one
microphone because I only have one
microphone to yell and scream into
but so do you and it is Thousands tens
of thousands of microphones
and the other thing that I want you to
do is I want you to consider highly
looking at these images I'm telling you
it's going to change how you interact
with someone about this situation if
they're challenging you on well my ride
is uninfrangeable you can't infringe on
my I'm a real regular militia blah blah
blah yakety schmackity let me tell you
something these images are gonna change
how you interact with those people and
how you how you say no that is it is not
your god-given right
for that little baby to have their head
blown off and their brains laying all
over the sidewalk that's not the price
of Freedom that's not the price of
Freedom it is not we do not have to live
with that we do not
have to compromise that that is not the
price of freedom and we don't have to do
it we just don't and we shouldn't and we
should be yelling and screaming at the
top of our lungs so do me the favor if
you've got a phone if you if you need to
look up your Congress person just Google
it who is my congressperson they'll ask
you for your your zip code and it'll
tell you all the people with their
numbers and [__] call them one today
one tomorrow one the next day if you
don't get them online leave a message
don't be an [__] just tell them we
need gun reform now I do not want people
being killed like people are being
killed down in Allen Texas in front of a
shopping mall like kids were being
killed in Nashville like kids are being
killed in Uvalde like Shoppers will be
killed in Buffalo New York it's enough
it's enough of this [__] [__] I
would also go as far as to say when
you're on the phone with them don't just
say you know do like you know do what do
what you should right [__] threaten
in the sense of and when I say that I
mean to primary right I will support I
will make sure that you get primaried
because when it comes to reelection that
they don't really care about that [__]
but when it comes to a primary that's
the [__] that they care about see I will
back I will support I will [__] make
sure that there is a Congregation of
people that support the person that is
going to primary your seat your position
and you bring that up and you tell them
I'm going to support your opponent I'm
going to support the other person that
wants to run for the seat in primary
you tell them and you you repeat it and
you say look I am I am [__] fed up
right I mean whether you want to say
[__] or not but you
honestly at this point it's like just
like representative Wu said right it's
the idea or is he a senator or statement
he's a state he's a state rep in Texas
State Rep right and the idea just at the
end he's like please
please just like this simple [__]
pleading
and you know if you want to go into
Representatives Wu argument whether you
believe it or not I actually believe
that it's a good paradigm shift and say
I'm the answer to your thoughts and
prayers tell that to your Congress
people especially if they're saying
thoughts I'm the answer to your thoughts
and prayers I will back you I will make
sure and listen I I want you to
understand something until
until White
privileged rule folks that are members
of the NRA part of the gun lobby who
backed the second amendments start
speaking out loudly that is going to
change it too so don't forget that that
just because we're not aligned exactly
on guns doesn't mean your voice doesn't
matter because the people who can stop
gun violence the most are the ones who
can hold their Republican politicians in
White America to account
stop being cowards we gotta stop being
cows we have to speak out it is enough
of this and by speak out I just don't
mean tweet I mean you need to call these
people you need to get your voice heard
on record and you know frankly the the
lines are open to Ted Cruz and John
cornyn they're the senators in Texas
there's plenty of Representatives
there's a representative a Republican
representative of Allen Texas
um State Rep the State Rep was one of
the main sponsors on the on the uh Carey
law that there is no background who can
ever get a rival he voted for those
folks to be killed at h m i don't give a
[__] what you say he voted for it he
voted for it he sponsored the bill
and they need to be held to account
the people who are setting these
policies they're allowing these guns to
be dumped on the streets
and what at the cost of what children
having their faces blown off go look at
the pictures if you don't [__]
believe me go look at them
everybody
we're gonna keep our our outrage going
here I promise you I'm not gonna stop
being pissed off about this
I'm just um I'm damn glad I did eat this
microphone today I'm so pissed off about
this but uh go
go listen to uh Jean Wu again and go
look at those images and you will feel
the same way he feels I'm telling you
you will if if you haven't got there on
the Second Amendment and you're not
there on gun safety yet I'm telling you
those images will put you in a place
where you'll start to have a paradigm
shift in your thoughts and your prayers
and your feelings about who should and
who shouldn't have guns everybody make
sure to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast here on YouTube don't forget
don't forget to download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify and Google
follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and also make sure you're
linking your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account give us that one
free subscription you get with your
Prime account it's an easy free way to
give us monetary Support also I want to
thank Jim over there our new mod on the
Empire go over to acwire.com go to the
up wires YouTube channel welcome Jim as
our new motto there also while you're
out on the internet search and and doing
some stuff go to what was thatshow.com
that's what was that show.com or
patreon.com slash I am Gabe Sanchez and
go visit his patreon page you guys watch
the brand new up episode even no one had
some commercials in it yeah yeah it
happens yeah but but go go check out all
the extras that you can find on
patreon.com I am Gabe santis for all his
new what was that episodes why you're on
patreon.com visit my page as well
at excuse me patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or you can just search the Tony
Michaels on patreon.com or you can go to
the Tony michaels.com and you can find
my patreon page there the link now I
promised I would have the rake merch we
are so close we are so close Gabe's
ninjas I really believe that tomorrow
morning where the final design
it's just it needs a few more tweaks
don't you agree like there's a couple
there's a couple small things a couple
small things that we're waiting on the
artist to do so hopefully we'll have
that tomorrow we'll have it in the merch
store for you hopefully by tomorrow on
the show time if not afterwards uh
everybody same time same place tomorrow
same [__]
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon